you know I used to say we have to stay
in these parties because certainly gay
people do not want to become a
Democratic Party constituency that is
totally taken for granted which is of
course what has happened when you have
no leverage over party they don't do
anything for you except take your money
and invite you to cocktail parties which
has always happened really in two years
under Obama with two houses of Congress
but at the same time you know this homo
Kahn thing it was in someone's apartment
I mean the idea that this has any any
genuine meaning out there for most
people there are plenty of gay people
many many many more I think than other
minority groups actually who would love
a party of limited small government
prudent strong foreign policy balanced
budgets live and let live
like the British Tories and if the
Republican Party ever becomes that again
I think there'll be plenty of place for
gay people in it but our but but to do
so and join a party on condition that we
oppose our own civil rights and our own
basic civil equality seems a non-starter
for me I mean it's it's um there's
something quite nauseating about it
actually and you see even like Chris
Baron who's the head of homo Khan or
whatever they're calling themselves
Geo proud having to say that when Jim
DeMint goes on and says no gay person
should be a schoolteacher which is to
the you know which Ronald Reagan
rejected in 1978
where are you left I mean it's also
important to remember that the
Republican Party is now a southern party
so so the older Republican Party which
was which had a balance of different
regions and was based also in the
libertarian West and remember how
Goldwater ended up and and of course
many elites Republicans by which I mean
a lot of people in Washington completely
comfortable and accept
thing of of gay people and you know
support our right to marry and I'll
right to serve our country without lying
about ourselves which are just the two
non-negotiables but they are cravenly
incapable of either understanding the
importance of that or taking us
seriously as human beings I mean I'm
sorry but Dick Cheney to the not gonna
pass Mary Cheney who is organizing got a
Republican majority that will make sure
that gay people never serve openly in
the military and support a Republican
party in her own state that would strip
over even the most basic contractual
rights with her with her wife and
children at this point I'm sorry but but
no
they have to vote for whichever
candidate they think is the least worst
option not and of course we don't just
vote on our sexual orientation and on
the critical critical issues a critic of
marriage it's fundamentally a state
issue anyway although DOMA remains a
terrible blight upon our national
federal equality so I believe never been
a partisan I've never been a Republican
I've never been a Democrat ever which is
why it was very frustrating to be kept
called a gay Republican when I had never
attached myself I'm for that you just
have to keep going I mean I think our
job my job is to keep articulating that
I exist and that lots of people like me
exist and we just have no home but if
temporarily we seek a home with Obama or
with with with people who are least less
hostile to us and we are not also too
opposed to their other policies then
that's the compromise that we all have
to make